hey gina you know any scalpers
i want to ask rosa to go to the rihanna
concert with me but it's sold out
okay two points to make here first
rihanna
you and then rihanna
yeah what's your second point she's got
a type
which is really anyone but you yeah that
was my ex-wife's type too
look a rihanna concert's a pretty big
swing man
i don't know she's into watching old
movies cool
where would i find a place to chose old
movies oh yeah
just go on the internet and search for
the phrase i want to buy two movie
tickets
for a girl who doesn't like me great
thank you hey rosa rosa um
i i just happen to notice that uh
there's an old movie festival
play at the film forum this week
you want to go sure
cool awesome there's a bunch of movie
options i'll probably just go
with something classic like citizen kane
citizen kane is terrible pick a good
movie
good call smart i'll do it
i'll pick a better movie than citizen
kane
my last meal on earth that's a great
question
i'd go classic french orderlan
tiny songbird eat in a single bite bones
and all
an open defiance of god it's illegal to
consume more to lunch
but i actually got academic dispensation
to eat one once
the beak very crunchy that is literally
the sexiest thing anyone has ever said
how were you single you're not seeing
anyone
no there's nobody in my life
sort of a sad thing to wink about i
realize now
i can't believe i'm frenching in the
closet i feel like a teenager
i feel like i'm 40 again chewing this
[ __ ] leaf
it'll give our kissing umami flavor
oh charles your jump off is here hello
detective
hello lieutenants real tragic about the
captain
yes real tragic i like the way your butt
looks today
i've been doing lunges in the shower
well this got upsetting real quick
i want to live in this moment forever i
got us a hotel room across the street
meet me there at 15 minutes i'll meet
you all right
m-e-a-t
still think it's creepy yes
charles it is not like you to have sex
with a total stranger
really tell it to me in an hour when
we've had sex 23
times whoa whoa whoa can we slow down
why are you not into this no no no my
friends are just
in my head they think it's weird that we
don't know anything about each other
i think it's hot totally i'm glad we're
not interested in each other as human
beings
oh how about if you tell me things about
yourself and then i tell you how little
i care about them
okay okay here goes
i'm an only child not interested i was
born in delaware who even asked you
i like that i don't care what you like
but maybe you could tell me one more
thing she's a vegan
what is going on you're right i couldn't
help myself i wanted to know about her
and i got what i deserved
a vegan a gluten-free vegan
charles you need to calm down no you
called it rosa so go ahead
laugh at me laugh laugh it up
can i wait till after the funeral shh
of course you can interesting yeah
something definitely doesn't add up did
you know there's a sausage you can drink
what are you even talking about the case
oh we got distracted
oh she has an amazing tongue strong
supple great bud density
okay i'm gonna take over the question
yeah i'm too close to this disgusting
eating habit
bouche monger oh small plates casual
chic ambiance no free soda refills
cheeky's going on a date
are you going on a date with amy what no
why uh because you guys just kissed on
that mission
charles we just kissed cause we were
undercover that's it yeah it didn't mean
anything
not that it's any of your business boyle
but the person that i'm taking on a date
is a girl from the gym what why is this
the first time i'm hearing about her
or that you go to the gym jake avoid the
weights
nobody wants you turning into another
terry ugh hey
people like the way that i look sure
they do big guy
rosa why are you sequestered over by
this old cell phone
i'm avoiding boyle and his truth bombs i
sometimes worry i'm going to become
you keep saying he wants to talk to me
i'm afraid he's gonna tell me he loves
me or
proposed marriage or something oh my god
that makes me kind of want to cry
he dove in front of those bullets for me
i can't be mean to him
i watched him make coffee for 28 minutes
this morning
hey i need to talk to you oh it's
happening
remember when i took those bullets for
you okay let's do this
i think you're sweet how did you know it
was you
when i jumped in front of those bullets
i didn't know who i was protecting
i just saw a gun and a nypd vest and so
i dove on instinct
you've been extra nice to me because you
thought i'd risk my life for you but
i only did what every good cop would do
when you finally go out with me and you
will it'll be because i do things that
only charles boyle would do
um actually i have a coat in here it's
uh
it's like it's actually i see it so how
was the restaurant
such a normal time why are you being
weird
amy and i kissed what to keep our cover
from being blown
we didn't have a choice tell me
everything
charles it was just a kiss okay it was
for work it was nothing
yeah who cares about a kiss call me if
you grab each other's asses
he's pulling over it's going down you
guys are so naive
it's never nothing in high school i
played daddy warbucks and annie
beckham merce played annie and we were
supposed to hug on stage
at first that seemed like nothing too
but by opening night
we were full-on making out as daddy
warbucks and annie
the audience was not on board
playwrights through the school
jakey hey are you guys wearing one scarf
yep charles forgot his this morning it's
actually quite romantic i think he did
it on purpose
uh let's just say i definitely did it on
purpose now twirl me darling
you got it sweet potato i can't get away
from you all right
you guys are adorable no no no no no
loyal can we please just go to dinner no
no no no no
this is not how you and amy are supposed
to end you're supposed to grow old
and die holding each other as your
cruise ship slowly takes on water
what do you want me to say we tried
really hard we made rules we kept it
light and breezy light and breezy
ow light and breezy is how you describe
a linen pants suit not a relationship
you care about we were just being
cautious
cautious now you guys started this with
one foot out the door
that's what doomed you not the universe
that actually makes a lot of sense
wow i was agreeing with you i'm sorry
i'm just so excited about all this
all right so what do i do tell me easy
you march over there
you tell her how you feel and you bring
a fancy bottle of lavender shampoo
because shampooing woman's head is the
most erotic thing you could ever no
no shampoo that's the worst but i am
gonna go over there i'm gonna tell her
how i feel
yeah you go get her no wait until it
starts raining
no that's crazy go now okay nice
jeans boyle those are surprisingly
low-waisted
eyes up here gina i'm more than just a
piece of ass oh
not bad not bad an unlicensed cab driver
has been picking up taurus
driver takes the vix down under the bqe
robs him at gunpoint leaves him stranded
unfortunately because they're tourists
and our perp is not caucasian we don't
have a clear idea of what he looks like
he was either latino arab or mexican
either way very muslim
we'll go undercover dress us out of
towners hope the perp picks us up
don't worry sarge i'll know this guy
i can't believe i was just briefly
attracted to boyle
you